Florida's a pretty damn mediocre State
and what I mean by that is it's not a
particularly great state by any metric
and it's not a particularly terrible
state by any metric but calling it a
miracle is weird Health Care is ranked
25th in Florida all right it's right in
the middle infrastructure is ranked 20th
in Florida crime is ranked 26th in
affordability Florida is 33rd there's
overall pretty good quality of life if
you have money in Florida and also if
you don't a lot of the metrics really
are lacking like it's just unremarkable
there's no big Florida story other than
the mediocrity that is the state of
Florida Saw DeSantis put kids back in
school faster than some other states
open sporting events with audiences
during covid faster than some other
states
some people liked it some people didn't
like it but that's it